avant d'être un homme politique vous
êtes d'abord un paysage celui de votre
valley la vallée das votre village
s'appelle lourdios ichère 136 âmes
aujourd'hui et tous les ans un rituel la
fête de la transhumance la montée des
troupeaux dans les hauteurs c'est un
reportage de 99 vous voir avec votre
béret faisait déjà le maire de ce
village
[Musique]
la transhumance une activité importante
en béarn 150 berger gagne les estives il
représente environ 450 éleveurs pour un
cheptel de près de 70000 brody et un
millier de vaches rassemblés à l'entrée
du village les touristes mais aussi les
habitants de la vallée sont venus
partager l'événement il troupeaux sont
marqués avant de gagner la montagne 90%
des actifs de lourdios cent des bergers
au des pasteurs étrangers mais en tout
cas et nous avons encore trente
exploitations agricoles qui sont
occupées d'insulter une proportion
ordinaire et puis comme vous le voyez
l'ensemble des prairies deschamps sont
entretenus je dirai pas ce que jardiner
ça a bougé depuis
est ce que ça changera vous me parlez
j'étais en train de me retrouver et
oui parce que malheureusement nous avons
perdu
beaucoup de bras exane a fini par nous
certaines rossi avec ma plus de retard
qu'ailleurs il y a un petit peu plus de
de rance et d'arbres qui ont poussé mais
malgré tout
c'est pas mal par rapport au reste du
territoire français qui nous ressemble
[Musique]